Finland is the guest of honor at the
Frankfurt Book Fair this fall we meet
one of the authors represented there
johani sepa vara is a writer originally
from Finland he now lives in Berlin he
used to work in the finance industry
before he quit to write books like this
one about life in East Berlin before the
Wall fell my semester here spool up
shooting it through Noland and he'll see
get it severe event all apollon on yoga
Steve Ellis to occur to you helloo TV i
t'ought up alica so yeah very carino
guilty encounter period rooster I don t
could only runs outta creepy popery
nearly coing so mr. Toyama kuroda a
colleague beta this one a pocket theory
history as I look at port appear
immediately east berlin capital of the
former communist East sep avarra got to
know it only a few years before the fall
of the wall he was fascinated by the
Prenzlauer Berg district back then it
was home to many artists and
nonconformists ya bang oh I wrote a book
about my experiences in east berlin and
Prenzlauer Berg during the 80s I also
took pictures back then thank goodness
so click
under the East Berlin sky is his first
book that's been translated into german
shep avarra won a prize for it back in
Finland it skipped elite crying algun
Flicka it's all about those small
moments and people that I met in chance
encounters it's not a political book but
entirely fictional that's big diva
today johani sepa vara lives in the
district featured in his book he moved
to Prenzlauer Berg five years ago his
apartment is a treasure trove of
memories and mementos of the past he's
published more than 20 books over the
years Mostyn finished about topics such
as design and the decline of rural
culture currently he's at work on a
memoir which will appear in the spring
in Finnish and German a man fun at first
my books were more documentary in
character my main topic was traditional
Finnish architecture and I spent a lot
of time traveling through Finland doing
research Damon you honey sepa vara grew
up in Helsinki in the 1950s he had a
carefree childhood much of it spent
outdoors after studying business at
university he spent 25 years working for
the finished state bank then he decided
to quit and live his dreams palma de la
pagina something as he leaned on his
abdomen vodka / 42 months out from yeah
here to tell us I'm I tell my stories
through people in their subjective
experiences that's my style of writing
the stagnant my steel
his account of traveling by moped
through Finland is about to appear in
German though finish authors are
relatively unknown abroad literature
holds a central place in Finnish culture
that's why Finland will be the guest of
honor at this year's Frankfurt Book Fair
feenin Leighton Jin's read a lot and
always have it's part of a long
tradition that's also why we have so
many authors finish crime novelists are
well-known and popular in Germany but I
hope that other forms of literature will
also be featured in Frankfurt accepted
Glendon
sefa Varro will also be one of the guest
authors at the Frankfurt Book Fair but
these days he sees himself as someone
with a foot in two worlds as a Finn who
has made his home in Berlin he scared of
Lebanon the way of life here in Berlin
is something special there are people
here from all over and it's easier to
talk to people here than anywhere else
I've been not just small talk but
conversation about all sorts of things
but always nervous and it's those
conversations and encounters that feed
into your honey's epijuarez writing